he joins us here back on the rich eyes
and show how you been grant I'm good I'm
good and I'm fired up excited about the
tournament and I'm good thanks for
having me on
okay so what what what is the one part
of the bracket you wish you could change
right now wave a wand grant he'll go for
it um you know I I'm a little surprised
that there's only one ACC team in the
eastern region you have nine ACC and
granted obviously I'm a little partial
to the ACC but yet nine teams
represented from that conference in this
tournament and everyone talked this year
that it was the strongest and the
toughest our uh conference or and the
fact that you know only one team which
was Virginia Tech as an eighth seed I
was a little surprised by that so anyway
that's that's what as I'm looking at my
sort of brackets right now that's the
thing that really sticks out we have
four in the Midwest two in the West and
two in the South Carolina you know they
were sent out as the number two sort of
from the ACC sent out west and Duke sent
to the Midwest so anyway that that was
that was what was surprising to me
initially now I know you were at the
American tournament final okay all
weekend long and part of the selection
show from there but my favorite part of
the entire selection show is when
Charles Barkley I had his one bite at
the Apple with what was that Brian
Rasmussen is that who that is was the
had Bruce Rasmussen pardon me who was in
charge of the committee and he basically
said to him with Oklahoma ten seed
despite finishing two and eight he goes
so what at Oklahoma started the one seed
first I mean so do you think they
deserve to be in the tournament right
wow that's a tough question yeah so we
were preparing for our little studio hit
and you know with Jim Nantz and Bill
Raftery and so we watched that so that's
actually the one thing that we saw on
our monitor was with Charles and I think
you made a valid point you know ten seed
is really interesting and particularly
with the team like Oklahoma
had really struggled you know as of late
and you know got off to a great start
but you know maybe the consideration of
thought process well they were in a
great conference they're in the big 12
but yeah I thought it was a great
question and I didn't get a great
answers I'm a little confused and for
for maybe you know what 1 out of you
know a few times in my life I agree with
Charles I mean during the television
portion of your answer there grant we
were showing video of Trey young that's
always showed of Oklahoma so maybe
that's why right I mean is that is that
it because there is is there in your
estimation now that you've been exposed
to this process with a front row seat in
a way over the last four or five years
grant that the tournament takes into
account who's playing on certain teams
and who might get in front of a
television set you know look I would
think from us from a TV standpoint yes I
mean I would think you know obviously
the network's love trade young and and
he's a great storyline he's been sort of
one of the main you know the main stars
if you will this year but I do think the
selection committee and the people that
I know or on that committee
you know they really take that job
seriously and so I you know I don't I
don't think that's the case but you know
hey I don't know everything either so
but you know it'll be interesting I mean
Oklahoma is a team in the first matchup
they'll have was with Rhode Island and
Danny Hurley has his guys playing at at
a great level but Wow imagine if like
Duke and Oklahoma met in the second
round so just you know purely as a fan I
wouldn't mind saying that but you never
know you never know what the total
metrics are or the thought process is
for the selection committee as they are
making these decisions here you know
leading up to the selection show Grant
Hill here on the Rich Eisen show part of
the selection show on TBS which will be
home to this year's final four national
semifinals and national championship
game he's here on the Rich Eisen show
all right grant
before we turn to the brackets a little
bit deeper where do you stand on the
latest Grayson Allen Kerr
fawful J Williams of the Duke community
of course also of the worldwide leader
in sports thought it was unfair that he
was called for a flagrant foul on a hip
check it was just because of Grayson
Allen where do you stand on that subject
as Coach K gets ready for another
tournament run ya Matic it was it was
nothing I mean obviously his past and
sort of things that have happened in the
past I think you know he's probably the
most scrutinized you know basketball
player and and in college basketball and
you know and look he's acknowledged that
he's made mistakes he's you know he's
he's sort of suffered I guess in a way
in terms of you know just you know being
booed and sort of becoming a villain and
so on and so forth but you know you have
a great year and you know it's
unfortunate that this has sort of come
up but he's a good kid I think you know
he and that team will be focused and you
know be ready for a nice run and you
know the beautiful thing I always feel
that once we get to Thursday it's just
like it's all about the games you know
it's all about what's happening that day
that moment you're in and you're out
great things occur and so I you know I
think this this is nothing like what had
happened you know years past with
Grayson well unless you hip-checked
somebody in Dukes first-round game right
I mean then then we're talking about
that again I mean yeah well I mean you
know hip check is a little different
than the trip okay so then how does
coach Kay change does he change when it
comes tournament time what what is he
like right I mean I play for him so long
ago rich but I mean I think I think the
basic tenants are the same in his
philosophy and particularly with the
program in the tournament you know first
of all he breaks it down into sort of
like three separate four game
tournaments and so right now they're
focusing on Iona Oklahoma and Rhode
Island and let's win this sort of
four-game tournament this weekend and
that's the approach obviously not
looking past the first opponent but
sometimes you can be overwhelmed and
look at the whole tournament the
totality of it all but the schools that
are playing the excitement but to really
kind of just focus in and lock in as a
team on those four
throughout the regular season rich
you'll have a series of games where you
might play two games in three days and
it's not exactly like a tournament you
know you're not in a neutral site it's
not it may be a home or away game but
that whole thinking is let's prepare
let's get a win and then we have a quick
turnaround we have to prepare quickly we
cover get ready and then be ready to be
at full tilt the next game and so all of
that through the regular season is
really to prepare you for now and as you
start this first week that preparation
that focus is no different now than it
is two weeks from now when you get to
the Final Four so you know that that was
sort of the approach back in the early
90s I'm sure he's you know he's added to
it he's tweaked it he's perfected it but
it certainly worked for us and it seems
to continue to work for him through the
years a couple more minutes with Grant
Hill do you still fill out a bracket you
know I used to fill out when I played in
the NBA we you know we would do that and
you know I'd always pick Duke to win so
you know every five or six years I might
win the whole thing okay you know it's
funny now that you know in this
broadcasting role I know Jim and Bill
will do that and not not to Tibet but
just to sort of see if they're right I
don't I kind of just focus in on it's a
little bit like the Duke approach that
we had as a team I focus in on those
eight schools that I have this first
week and I'm just totally locked in and
try to absorb as much as I can about
these teams how they play style of play
personalities storylines all of that and
so it's really kind of an interesting
week where you just you're just studying
like you feel like you're back in
college you know I'm cramming for you
know midterms or final exams but you
really want to try to do these guys just
as paint you know pay respect to their
slips commit first time they've ever
been in an NCAA tournament now it's a
little unfortunate they're playing North
Carolina not an easy opponent but really
try to tell their story and and just you
know give them in paper space
sort of what they've accomplished and
and so that's the fun part you know
getting learning about these teams and
and learning about you know their
stories and and so during that week
though you you you watch games and we go
to dinners and we you know so we're
aware of what's happening but it's a
long answer to your question so I don't
fill out brackets so do you have a final
four then final four prediction you know
I haven't done that but I'll sit here
look now I think I think
Villanova has the easiest route to the
final four okay
no disrespect to the teams in that
region but I think Villanova can get
there you know III want to go UVA but
they've had some some troubles in in the
tournament you know I think it's
interesting Arizonans of for like I want
to see that Arizona Kentucky match up um
but I think I think Arizona can kind of
get out of that region okay Jude asked
me a week ago I might I might have said
in Michigan in the West but I am a
little concerned that they had that
extra week off and for a team that was
playing so well and playing uh such a
high level you know that rest
how do you stay sharp and so I you know
okay III guess I might go Xavier UNC huh
okay and then in the Midwest in the
Midwest I think that's the toughest
region and I mean that's a toss-up you
talk about championship pedigree Kansas
Duke Michigan State is okay Bill Self
Auburn's have it a magical season you
know would you be mad if I picked up no
it's true to form yeah you know and look
I picked a lot of high seeds and and and
you know Arizona was a four seed in the
South Region yeah but the crazy thing
this year rich is that there's like this
there's really no dominant team that you
just you know like a it could be you
know it could be a five six seven see
getting to the to the Final Four from
regions and I think the parity right now
in college basketball is really
interesting it should make for an
exciting couple of weeks here
we lead up to the Final Four well done
grande he'll always enjoy our chats
let's chat during the tournament and and
stay in touch appreciate I appreciate
your it's fake you always at real Grant
Hill 33 on Twitter so Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience